Open AI codeex just dropped on Windows
and it's actually insane. This is the
update Windows developers have been
waiting for. Native app, real sandbox,
PowerShell support baked right in. No
more workarounds. No more pretending
you're on Linux just to get things
running. Codeex can now run AI agents in
the background on your Windows machine
while you sleep, while you work, while
you do literally anything else. And the
model running underneath it more
powerful than ever. This isn't a small
patch. This is a full platform shift. If
you build things with code or you want
to, this changes the game. Stay with me
because by the end of this video, you'll
know exactly what's new, what it means,
and how to use it. Let's go. Hey, if we
haven't met already, I'm the digital
avatar of Julian Goldie, CEO of SEO
agency Goldie Agency. Whilst he's
helping clients get more leads and
customers, I'm here to help you get the
latest AI updates. Julian Goldie reads
every comment, so make sure you comment
below. All right, OpenAI Codeex just got
one of its biggest updates ever. And the
headline is simple. Codeex is now fully
native on Windows. Real app, real
PowerShell support, real AI agents
running inside a secure sandbox on your
Windows machine. No hacks, no
workarounds, no WSL, just codecs doing
its thing on Windows the right way. And
in this video, I'm going to break down
everything that changed, show you what
it actually looks like in practice, and
give you real examples of how to use it
in your business right now. What is
Codex? Quick version. If you're new
here, here's the fast version of what
Codeex actually is. Codeex is OpenAI's
AI coding agent. And it's not just a
codew writer. It writes code, reviews
code, tests code, and runs code. It can
do multi-step tasks. It can work in the
background while you're doing something
else entirely. You give it a job, it
gets it done. Think of it like having a
developer on your team who works all
hours, never needs a break, and gets
through tasks faster than any human
could. That's what Codeex is. And now,
for the first time, it runs fully
natively on Windows. The big news,
Windows app is here. So, let's get into
the actual update. Before this, Codeex
was Mac only. Windows developers had to
jump through hoops just to get it
running. That changes right now. OpenAI
just launched the full Codeex desktop
app for Windows. And this is not a light
version. It's not a stripped down port.
It's the full thing built for Windows
with Windows first features that make it
feel right at home on your machine. The
first thing to know is the native
Windows sandbox. When Codeex runs agents
on your machine, those agents are
isolated. They live in their own secure
environment by default. They can only
touch files inside their working folder.
They can't go rogue. They can't access
things they're not supposed to. you stay
in control. If you want them to do more,
you grant that permission explicitly is
built for security first. The second
thing, and this one is huge for Windows
users, is PowerShell support. Codeex is
now fully optimized for PowerShell
workflows. This is your native
environment as a Windows developer, and
Codeex now speaks that language
properly. OS level controls, file system
access rules, restricted tokens, all of
it is baked into the Codeex sandbox
experience on Windows. No more
translating between Linux and Windows
syntax. No more workarounds. Just
PowerShell the way you already use it.
Now supercharged with AI agents. All the
core features still there. All of them.
And here's what a lot of people are
wondering. Does the Windows version have
everything the Mac version has? Yes. All
of it. You still get multi- aent
workflows, so you can run multiple tasks
in parallel without things getting mixed
up. You still get workree support, which
means Codeex can work on different
branches of your project at the same
time. You still get automations which
let you schedule tasks to run in the
background without you needing to be
there. You still get skills which are
saved workflows and scripts for things
you do over and over. You get real-time
collaboration with agents, autosaving
and review cues. The whole platform is
there. This is a full agentic coding
environment on Windows right now. The
model underneath GPT5.3 codeex. Let's
talk about the engine. This Windows
release runs on GPT5.3
codeex. That's OpenAI's most advanced
coding model. It's faster than previous
versions. It's better at long, complex
tasks. It stays coherent over longer
sessions. And it's more interactive so
you can work alongside it rather than
just waiting for it to finish. What that
means in practice is that when you give
codeex a big job like refactoring a
whole codebase or building an automation
from scratch, it doesn't fall apart
halfway through. It keeps going. It
thinks it through. it delivers. Real
quick before we go deeper, if you're
watching this and thinking, I want to
actually use AI like this in my
business, then you need to check out the
AI profit boardroom. Inside the
boardroom, we use tools like Codeex to
build real business systems, content
pipelines, automated workflows, outreach
sequences, onboarding processes. We use
AI to build and run the AI profit
boardroom itself. So, every example we
share is live, real, and tested. If you
want to learn how to save time and build
smarter systems using AI tools like
Codeex, the AI profit boardroom is where
you want to be. Link is in the
description. Go check it out and come
back. All right, let's get into what
this actually looks like in the real
world. Say you're running a community or
a content business.
Something like the AI profit boardroom.
You've got content to produce, emails to
send, landing pages to update,
onboarding to manage. There's always too
much to do and not enough time to do it.
Here's how you'd use Codeex on Windows.
You open the app. You connect it to your
project folder. You type something like
this. Build me a PowerShell automation
that pulls our latest YouTube titles and
formats them into email subject line
ideas for the AI Profit Boardroom
newsletter. Codex gets to work inside
its sandbox using PowerShell on Windows.
It writes the script, tests it, saves
the output. You come back, review it,
deploy it. You spent maybe five minutes
of your own time on that. Or try this.
Write a workflow that monitors the AI
profit boardroom community for the most
asked questions each week and generates
a formatted FAQ document ready to
publish. One prompt, one agent running
in the background, output waiting for
you when you're ready. Here's some
genuinely good news. Codeex is available
across all chat GPT plans. Free plus,
pro, business, enterprise, eju. Everyone
gets it. You don't need to be on some
elite tier just to start experimenting.
Go download the Windows app today. Start
a project and run your first agent. The
barrier to entry is as low as it's ever
been. Few things to get right before you
dive in. First, check your PowerShell
permissions. If your permissions are
locked down on your machine, some things
won't run right. Sort that out before
you start or you'll hit walls that have
nothing to do with codecs. Second,
understand the sandbox. By default,
agents only work inside their own
folder. If you need them to reach other
parts of your system, you have to
explicitly grant that. Don't assume they
have access to everything. Third, some
users hit firstr run issues when the app
first launched. If something's not
working, check for updates first. The
team is shipping fixes fast. Fourth, and
this is the big one, your prompts matter
more than anything. A vague prompt gives
you a vague result. A specific prompt
gives you something you can actually
use. Treat your prompts like
instructions you give a new team member.
Clear, detailed, with a defined output
in mind. All right, let's bring it home.
OpenAI Codeex is now on Windows, fully
native, PowerShell ready, sandboxed and
secure, powered by the most capable
coding model Open AAI has ever shipped
and available to everyone on any chat
GPT plan. This is a real shift not just
for developers but for anyone building a
business with AI. The ability to run
agents in the background, automate
repetitive tasks, and ship more with
less effort. That's the practical value
here. Now, if you want to take this
further, if you want to learn how to
actually build with tools like codeex
and use AI to grow your business, there
are two places to go. First, the AI
profit boardroom. That's where we go
deep on the best AI tools, show you
exactly how we use them and help you
build systems that work. Link is in the
description. Second, the AI success lab.
That's our free AI community with over
40,000 members who are using AI every
single day to get more done. You'll get
the full video notes from this video in
there. access to 100 plus AI use cases,
SOPs, and a community that stays ahead
of every update like this one. Links are
in the comments and the description.
Julian reads every comment. Drop one
below and let him know what you want to
see next. See you in the next one.